time for the crypto corner we talk about
crypto all the time we want to know
what's going on crypto bitcoin is
booming right now let's see where
bitcoin is today
and we'll get into the top 10 cryptos in
the marketplace right now
crypto 54 265 is that where we are on
the screen crypto's up
so here according to forbes are the top
10 cryptocurrencies currently in the
marketplace obviously we know who's
number one but we'll get into that so
the market caps or pricing are based on
the beginning of october so by time this
comes out it might be a couple days
later anyway obviously we all know
cryptos right on the blockchain
blockchain is a quote unquote
ledger logging transactions across a
network of computers
i like to call it they're like the court
stenographer they're just writing down
everything that's going on out there
everything's on the blockchain so number
one the number one cryptocurrency we all
know
is bitcoin all right market cap one
trillion dollars it was created i think
in 2009 satoshi nakamoto we all know
this guy it's the original og
crypto five years ago you can bought
bitcoin for you know how much 500 bucks
now it's across 50 grand
okay it's a 10 000 roi 10 000. that's
number one
bitcoin number two
ethereum
market cap 425 billion
ethereum is both a crypto
and a blockchain platform crypto um
cryptocurrency and blockchain platform
so the reason that people love
ethereum is because the applications
they can use on it they call they talk
about smart contracts or nfts to go on
the blockchain on ethereum right so it's
not a currency it's a
it's a platform
okay ethereum cool so in five years it
went from 11 bucks to now closer to 35
hundred bucks it's a 27 000 yeah roi
it's at 36.42 right now 36.42 okay i
said 3 500 all right 36 thank you number
three the number three cryptocurrency is
tether market cap close to 70 billion
dollars tellers what's called a stable
coin yeah okay meaning it's backed by
fiat currencies like the dollars and the
euro okay that's what that is so it
keeps its value more and more consistent
other cryptocurrencies so if you're like
dude i can't even deal with crypto it's
so freaking volatile i'm up i'm down i'm
left i'm right
this has a value close to the u.s dollar
so it's worth about a dollar boom number
four the number four cryptocurrency is
called cardano it has a market cap of 73
billion dollars it's notable for its
early embrace of the proof of stake
validation you're not proof of like
steak
yeah proof of stake s-t-a-k-e no i
gotcha okay gotcha i don't know you're
looking roi roi
getting hungry so the reason the cardano
people like that is because it expedites
transaction time and decreases
energy usage a lot of complaints with
crypto is it uses a lot of energy in the
environment what have you this is what
cardona was known for in 2017 cardano
was
two cents
two cents it is now
two dollars and thirty cents that is
over a ten thousand percent return on
investment irr wow uh number five is the
binance coin market cap 68 billion
dollars these things are no joke binance
coin you can trade and you can pay fees
on binance which is basically one of the
largest cryptocurrency exchanges it
launched in 2017 its price was 10 cents
now 440 bucks so let me let me ask you
000 return on investment okay sick let
me ask you a rookie question here from
uh uh amateur crypto guy yep
the market cap you said it was 600 and
what
68 billion 68 billion so that's what it
what does that mean is that the highest
market capitalization okay how much it's
worth in the marketplace look it up get
the definition right there
let's see
maybe a rookie question but no all good
get the actual definition of market cap
coming up
crypto market capitalization is the
total value of cryptocurrency we're
starting total value
wall companies shares and stuff gotcha
we're stock markets calculated by
multiple multiplying share price times
share outstanding crypto market
capitalization is calculated by multiple
share price times share outstanding okay
cool all right good just learn that
so
bitcoin is the first
to cross a trillion right all these
other things um ethereum
just under half a trillion dollars 425
billion right basically there's like how
much money is in the marketplace for
this
asset okay total that's how they told
the market cap the market capitalization
sick and you just read the um the
formula good question david thank you
where'd we leave off on binance coin
there was number six
is xrp these are from the founders of
ripple okay so market cap 50 billion
dollars at the beginning of 2017 the
price of xrp was
.006 it is now a dollar that's at over
an 18 000
rate of return okay
return on investment there it is number
seven is solano this is one that's
getting a lot of street cred out there
market cap 46 billion basically it
depower it powers
d5 you know what d5 stands for no
decentralized finance that's what all
this stuff is
powers
these defy apps and these smart
contracts right okay so rather than old
school contracts pen and paper boom it's
all done on the blockchain cool so it
was launched in
um solano's price started at 0.77 less
than a dollar it's now 150 bucks that's
18 000
rate of return
okay return on investment so alana's
developers claim
is the fastest blockchain in the world
it is censorship resistant and it will
carry transactions as fast as news
travels around the world hot tip look
into solana number eight is the usd coin
there's a market cap of 32 billion so
just like tether that's decoin yeah
exactly exactly it's a stable coin so
just remember remember we talked about
yeah tether it's a stable coin meaning
it's backed by fiat currencies yeah okay
same thing
with the usd coin
so
a penny like yes no it's backed by u.s
dollars okay and aims for a one-to-one
usd so usdc ratio one dollar one coin
exactly that's what it's going for so
this one is powered by ethereum and you
can use usd coin to complete global
transactions okay cool we're learning
stuff stable coin stable coin the whole
thing with crypto is that it's volatile
this is stable number nine is polka dot
i've heard a lot about polka dot market
cap 35 billion it's basically a crypto
network that connects the various
blockchains so everything's run on the
blockchain polkadot is like all the
blockchains can work together now okay
so it's that it's had crazy growth since
it started in 2020 price go from three
to thirty four to
thirty four dollars the thousand percent
return
um
anyway this is connecting various
blockchains never even heard about that
boom yeah i mean number ten
this one gets [ __ ] on a lot uh say it
it's dogecoin i know so obviously we
know that elon musk pumping this one up
the pump and dump all the memes it
started as a joke but now apparently
it's real it's the top
top 10 cryptocurrency the problem with
it
the problem with it is there's no no
limit on the number of dogecoins that
can be
created so that lowers value exactly
exactly it's called devaluation as
supply increases is there a bad is there
a reason that you know of that there is
no
these are the creators of dogecoin i
don't know why would you have no those
guys don't you have those coins i do
have dosh because it's good to know well
this is bad for me to know that that's
like well there's a you can make
infinite amount so there's 27 value okay
well i don't know i wouldn't say that
i'm selling it right now in 2017 it was
worth point zero zero zero two cents
yeah like
point zero zero zero two is now as much
as 25 cents
that's a hundred thousand
percent increase okay
um
based on a meme it was started as a joke
so that's that's a crypto word for it
anyway so this growth obviously the
groups the growth of crypto has been
astronomical to the moon to the moon to
the moon yeah obviously someone that's a
big proponent of mutual funds and index
funds and maxing out your 401ks and your
iras that's great that's the main
that's the main dish but some of this
crypto can be the side pieces right the
appetizers right so look into it that's
all i'm saying
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken